how you gonna forget about the one who
made you the one who fashioned you in
your mother's womb brought you into
existence when you weren't even a thing
worth mentioning you forgot about the
time that nobody even knew you you
didn't even exist can you spend some
time and your mother's then came out and
look at you now
you forgot to give thanks to the one who
made this happen how long grateful is
that
if someone took you in fed you clothed
you gave you money filled up your bank
account you would at least say thank you
and you would be indebted to this person
but the one who gave you priceless gifts
those eyes that you see with our
priceless the hands that you touch with
our priceless the heart that pumps
constantly keeps the body alive it's
priceless we cannot enumerate the
priceless gifts that money can't buy
that money can't replace that you've
been given are you too arrogant to thank
the one who has provided you with all
these things to show thanks and
gratitude
you